what's this one now it's a dance of
dragons a true telling by Grandma
that sounds like a proper story
no it's story of the fight between Renee
Targaryen and the thought by the Dragon
for control of the Seven Kingdoms
both of them thought they belonged on
the iron throne
when people started declaring for one of
them or the other their fight divided
the kingdoms in Two Brothers Four
Brothers Dragon spot dragons
by the time it was over
thousands were dead
and there was a disaster for the
Targaryen as well they never truly
recovered
dragons
why is that a dance
it's just what they call it
it makes sense
I think it's poetic
[Music]
rhaenira Targaryen was murdered by her
brother or brother his Dragon it ate her
while her son watched
if you had to choose
I wouldn't have chosen either
I saw the choosing sides to make
everything so horrible sometimes a
person has to cheat
two years until season two is a long
period but you can still stay in the
house of the Dragon World by listening
to Fire and Blood audiobook for free
house of the Dragon is based on Fire and
Blood book and covers the entire
Targaryen history starting from aegon
the Conqueror and his Conquest as well
as Mega the cruel and other legendary
targaryens including the current and
future events of House of the Dragon go
and listen to it for free with horrible
trial using our Link in the description
foreign